mike i felt bad i felt bad after
yesterday's show
let me tell you why why
i really uh i really was not nice
talking about the new york jets
i went on them i said they've been
tanking since 1969. i i got some good
lines off though i got some good lights
off
at the expense of the jets but that
whole conversation started
um because i told you like my feelings
for for bill cowart i'm a big fan of his
uh had the opportunity to talk with him
you know several times over the over the
last
couple of years and enjoyed our
conversations very much so our whole
conversation started with
hey do i think bill cower is going to
become the head coach of the jets
yeah boomer cyrus and threw it out on
wfan that at that job that he's
that coward talked up that job uh behind
the scenes at cbs yeah
and and and knowing knowing coward the
way i do
uh with all respects to uh boomer or
sias and
i think what coward did with that job is
what he does with
everything that he talks about he he
gives you he'll give you like the pros
and cons
of a situation he'll tell you what's
good about the situation
and then he'll tell you what what he
doesn't like and so
i i i'll be shocked
i'll be shocked okay if bill cower
takes over the jets because i know this
portion
so did we blow this out of proportion i
think so by by we i mean everybody
like everybody because remember what i
said yesterday i took it not only did i
take it as boomer has insight
i took it as boomer wouldn't run to a
microphone with that without not only
bill cower's blessing but perhaps even
his instruction
maybe he wanted it kind of floated out
there that he was looking to get back in
sounds like i went too far in that
assumption yeah i think boomer's like
look boomer he he was an mvp quarterback
you know what he is now he's a media guy
with a talk show
so what a talk show host do yeah think
about that first he's a talk show host
and a studio analyst in new york
so hey let me just let me just
let me throw it out headline see how it
goes made headlines yeah
and made headlines i would say bill
cower
does he like does he like coaching would
the jets intrigue him
no i'm sure i might intrigue him you
know what he likes more than coaching
his life chilling
his wife is a jets fan you know you know
who his wife loves more than the jet her
husband
her husband so i just i don't see that
happening i don't see him
uh going to the jets but i can see why
somebody would be i
understand why somebody would be
interested in the jets nowhere to go but
i'm new york nowhere to go but up
you're right you know still in new york
i will yeah
not a history of winning yeah they you
know how much cap space they have mike
uh 83 million dollars
and that's what you get when you don't
spend it on talent or you don't oh
you're trying to get
a rookie contract even better though but
eat a lot of clothes look at this cash
race
well look at your jaguars i know you're
getting excited i know you're excited
with that chart
i know you like that now it's a great
website i don't know if you look okay
go to spokestrack.com that's a great
website i have um let me let me talk
about you real quick oh go ahead i was
gonna say well i was just gonna say this
if you have 85 million dollars in cap
space or 83
roughly rounding up the jets have you've
already got
a left tackle and beckton who's very
good so you don't have to pay a left
tackle he's going to be great
you're going to get a top at least one
or two pick at quarterback
you're not going to have to pay that guy
big dow big dollars initially
so you think like got two expensive
positions taken care of and left tackle
or
rookie quarterback yeah now you
you go out and get your corner back get
another expensive position
cornerback and d in you got a lot of
money to spend you're in new york city
you're in a division that's that that
could be competitive but it's not out of
your in transition division
yeah um i want i want to i want a little
bit more of this reported column because
i know a reported column when i when i
read it from michael holly
um so coincidentally
the jets um
[Music]
just famously or infamously
lost to a raiders team coached by john
gruden and once upon a time and
as a former employee of espn i remember
this when john grew was in the booth on
monday night football
his name intentionally because he had a
good agent has a good agent
obviously his name every cycle
every hiring cycle was thrown out for
pro and college jobs
and it was like oh boo he's so happy in
the booth he's not he's not
he loves calling monday football he's
not coming back to coaching
raiders pointed up enough money 100
million dollars i believe
and he went back to the raiders and now
he's on the sideline again so okay
if not the jets my question to you as
our resident bill cower expert
is do you see coward coaching again
period or is he just
done no i don't okay
i don't see him coaching again i mean
he's in
he's in such a good place in his life
he's on
he's got a great schedule with cbs yeah
he's in new york he's grown she's got
grown children
who are very successful in their own
rights around the country
uh and he's going to the hall of fame
he's in a hall of fame yeah so he he's
he was at that intersection and this is
always a good place to be
like those coaches there are some
coaches who
just missed the the big paydays they met
they just missed them
like the league changed right after they
got out of the business
but he didn't i mean he's there for 15
years in pittsburgh
he's been in tv yeah add another 15
years in tv
uh i don't know i don't know what he
makes in cbs but i know they pay pretty
well
right i mean pay him
definitely he's fine i i just i think
he just said he's in a good position in
his life i don't see him coming back to
coach anybody
and and new york would make sense
because it's in his city
but that that's so much work that's
i honestly might i think that's starting
over that's starting over
because it's not just that organization
is broken in so many places if you
not just that if you like your life
you're not going back to that coaching
life because it's all-consuming
especially if you want to uphold the
standard that's gotten him
uh to the hall of fame to begin with hey
thanks for watching brother from another
on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you